[Music]
[Music]
I'm the one
we're ready all right all right all
right okay so this is
part two with the one and only Michael
Saylor obviously Michael from the last
time we sat down to today last time
Bitcoin was 44 000 today it's 17K
ethereum was three thousand today's
1262. I figured we do a part two because
it's been very quiet the last nine
months not much has happened in the
crypto it's not like there's been a guy
that screwed a lot of people over it's
not like there's a lot to talk about but
we're so happy I'm gonna have you back
here for part two I was worried uh you'd
be bored of me
I think that's the last thing yeah
crypto space very boring right now no
news nothing of no very big I ran out of
stuff to talk about well you know since
you ran out of stuff I think some people
worked very hard to create new content
for him to talk about so by the way have
you ever had any interaction with the
sandbankment freedom have you guys ever
spent time together I haven't spent time
with him but I've talked to him okay
what do you think like was anything
that's going on with him anything I mean
you're a guy that uh I've seen the
numbers I don't know what the numbers
today was it a hundred you own you own
139 000 Bitcoins that's a big number 130
000 100 microstrategy at micro Stratton
and that also doesn't include what you
have personally using yeah I own like
another 17. so 17 personal 113
000 not 17. correct yeah so so it's not
like you're
I'm somewhat long Bitcoin oh yeah I saw
what you said article you said if you're
this is the first uh bear Market if
you're in this business for just kind of
uh messing around and you know you're
not in it long term for four years
you're you're you're not doing your
self-adjustice but going back to SPF so
any of the stories that came about did
the did the guys in the industry like
yourself the heaviest were you aware
that something was going on at SPF or no
yeah I mean I I think that uh you have
the Bitcoin Community opposite the
crypto community and then there's been a
low grade sort of boiling Guerrilla war
between the two camps for the past two
and a half years and Sam is kind of like
the poster child of the crypto world
right Sam makes billions of dollars on
an unregulated exchange offshore he
makes billions of dollars issuing his
own air token he he uh spends hundreds
of millions of dollars giving to the
crypto Lobby and to politicians and one
of their messages is uh you know Bitcoin
is bad for the environment he uses too
much electricity but not to fear we have
a you know a staked air token which does
the same thing as Bitcoin and it's
environmentally friendly so you know we
we've always seen that going on and I
think that um you know the Bitcoin
Community would say you know there's
something ethically broken about being
able to issue your own unregistered
security right they call it committing
the sin of [ __ ] coinery yep right so so
Sam and most of the people in the crypto
world were always guilty of the scent of
[ __ ] coinery or pumping and promoting
unregistered Securities and and that was
obvious I think
um you know that that was obvious to the
chair of the SEC to most politicians
right that the phrase that pops up over
and over again is the vast majority of
all crypto tokens are unregistered
securities but I think the Diabolical
twist in the FTX story that none of us
saw coming but it is particularly
diabolical
so Sam creates you know uh eight billion
dollars worth of air token with SRM and
ftt then he issues himself locked token
secret locked token marks it up on his
balance sheet by another four to eight
billion dollars and calls at 16 billion
worth of collateral
okay then he goes shopping for a bank to
give him a loan against this well if I
took a billion dollars of Apple stock
and I went to a legit Bank Bank of
America JP Morgan Goldman Sachs I still
got a billion of Apple stock they would
say
well we won't give you collateral value
for up to the amount you have or five
percent of the daily trading liquidity
on a legitimate regulated Exchange so if
you show me a security that trades a
billion dollars a day and you have a
billion dollars of it I might give you
50 million a collateral value and that
means you could borrow 25 million
dollars against it at 50 loan to value
but I'm going to margin call you if it
moves a tick so it means practically
speaking a billion dollars of that legit
security is probably going to give you
10 million dollars worth of a loan on a
billion on a billion that's one percent
okay right because the the gating factor
is what's five percent of the trading
liquidity of that token or that asset
because if I have to dump that thing in
the market I want to sell the entire
position without uh moving the price
sure okay so that's the traditional
World on Shore what Sam did was
generated 14 to 16 billion dollars worth
of Solana you know ftt serum and then he
went shopping for a bank to give him a
loan but he didn't want uh you know you
wouldn't get a loan from Goldman Sachs
on it no one's going to borrow your
money at least no non-crypto company so
what he did was he went to himself he
runs a bank called FTX he applied for a
loan from himself he granted himself the
line for a loan from himself well
secretly applied he didn't tell anybody
but he when they say well Alameda had a
margin account and the margin position
was slightly bigger than I thought
what he means is oh yeah they pledged a
few billion dollars of error token gave
themselves a 10 billion dollar loan and
they extracted
even if he had pledged 15 billion worth
of air token giving yourself a 10
billion dollar loan means that you gave
yourself about a hundred X the
collateral value you would have got on a
regulated exchange on shore
so what he did was in essence extract 10
billion dollars of real stuff dollars
Bitcoin salable assets and he pledged
10 billion dollars worth of air token
stuff and of course the it's a double
diabolical thing here's here's the
problem so I create a token I have 300
million tokens and then I basically
trade it with myself like I give it to
you and you work for me and you give it
back to me then I lean on it so I lever
it up ten to one you know an FTX you
could lever it twenty to one then I
borrow your money you're a depositor so
I take your money you have 10 million
dollars I levered up twenty to one I
have 200 million dollars I buy my own
token I drive my token up by five bucks
five dollars times 300 million makes me
1.5 billion in collateral I post the
collateral and then I would draw one
billion dollars of
you know a hundred thousand people's
money
I put it in Alameda and then Alameda
gives a three and a half billion dollar
loan to Sam right to he gave 3.3 billion
to either himself or his personal Family
holding company
so here's the Diabolical twist I didn't
just generate 10 billion dollars of an
unregistered security to dump it on the
unsuspecting retail that would take me
500 trading days dumping 20 million a
day right they didn't do that what he
did is he generated a 10 billion dollar
in unregistered security and then just
borrowed 10 billion dollars secretly
from his depositors
and then went and gambled it traded it
spent it lost it how and that is like
it's particularly impressive how do you
so here's the question you know how you
he goes and he raises the two billion
okay and he gets the 2 billion from not
small people he gets it from the best of
the best of the best right you got
BlackRock you got inside I can you know
the names I don't need to give you the
names you know the name so page your
names then he they don't get any seeds
board seats in return these are very
very smart people who are seeing this
are they just as responsible for the
fall of FTX as sandbankment fritas uh
the Bitcoin maximalist would say that
the problem in crypto is greed arrogance
and foolishness okay okay anybody that's
investing in it is is either greedy
arrogant or foolish so there's three
constituencies that got taken for
billions of dollars here the VC
investors put two billion dollars into
an offshore exchange The Exchange just
to be clear was unethical and illegal
from the very beginning it's illegal to
do what they did in the U.S and it's and
and it's unethical if you think I'm
front running my customers issuing a
token manipulating the price of the
token dumping it on them if you did that
on stocks you're going to jail if you if
you front run it's not it's absolutely
yeah right FTX was its own regulator its
own Market maker its own exchange the
issuer right all all at the same time
this is this is such a con and a hedge
fund too much conflict of interest so
but the three constituencies are the VC
that put the two billion into into FTX
they were supporting basically an
offshore unregulated Casino you know
running an opaque fashion you know honor
the interest of its own customers they
didn't ask for a board seat they didn't
do due diligence they were chasing what
they thought was insane gains right FTX
is showing a company that goes from 50
million in Revenue to 500 million in
Revenue to a billion in revenue and they
thought they just had the next great
thing so you know Sam lies that any con
right is like I think I'm getting a deal
that's too good to be true and the con
man is lying to me we're all lying to
each other and and so that's the first
two billion goes down the drain
there's another 4 billion or something
like that and just loans made by you
know crypto industry I think Alameda
borrowed hundreds of millions and
billions of dollars from Genesis from
three arrows from Voyager from Celsius
from you know block Phi
Etc so it's like if you start with this
fiction that ft and T is ftt is a real
thing
if I create you know again like yo-yo
token and I and I manipulate the price
up to 10 billion dollars by trading two
percent of the float if you think it's a
real thing and I act like it's a real
thing then I pledge it is collateral and
you give me real stuff for air thing
and so there's like four billion dollars
of that and they went and they lost half
of that that they you know that was part
of the reason that Voyager and block fi
going bankrupt and the reason that Sam
wanted to bail them out is he didn't
want to actually have the loans called
right he was actually trying to buy
block fi and block buy Voyager with ftex
equity which of course is fraudulent and
worth nothing but if I borrowed a
billion dollars from a company and they
want the money back and I can simply
give them a billion dollars of equity
take over the company and not pay the
loan back I can roll the entire fraud
forward so that's the second the third
is you know they
this is also diabolical you know FTX
said you know we're built by Traders for
Traders and Sam Bragg that they only
charge like three basis points trading
fee and he was 30 times cheaper than
coinbase or much cheaper than binance so
he's stealing customers off of the other
crypto exchanges by in essence offering
near free Trading he's not trying to
make money off the trading he's trying
to actually get the assets on his
platform because once he had the assets
on his platform he basically used FTX
like his own personal piggy bank it's
like there's 10 billion dollars there
everybody else is going to get wiped out
if uh if their margin positions trade
down 20 percent for a minute
except Alameda Alameda has God mode they
never get margin called so in an
exchange you know like in in the US it's
illegal to go more than 50 loan to value
that means you're kind of like you start
with a million dollars you borrow 500
000 you're 1.5 x leverage
okay well FTX started with 100x leverage
and then they backed it down to the
responsible 20x leverage which means
that you post a million and you can take
a 20 million dollars okay who allows
that now here's the insane what if I put
a billion dollars of air token ftt on
the exchange I recognize you and I let
you take a 10 billion dollar bet
like whatever you took a 10 billion
dollar bet now you withdraw four billion
dollars of real cash and you use that to
buy property and buy everything under
the Sun so Sam basically he scraped
billions from unsuspecting investors in
Silicon Valley who they should have
known better he took billions from
crypto hedge funds and crypto Banks like
blockfi and Voyager they should have
known better and then he took probably
10 billion or more from depositors on
his Exchange
they they have the best argument it's
like they are staring at terms and
conditions that said he's not going to
re-hypothecate or use their assets and
he just you know he lured them with the
promise of cheap trading High leverage
and uh you know if you thought well Sam
is manipulating the price of FDT and
serum and Solana and he was right that's
illegal and unethical right your pump
it's a pump and dump scheme we talked
about this before but if you if you
accept the idea that crypto tokens that
are issued by some offshore you know
dude are okay then you're thinking well
I guess I want to go buy some of that
and and get behind Sam and Alameda
because they're going to drive the price
up and I think Solana went from you know
three bucks to want to go to 50 you know
it went way up and ftt went to fifty
dollars a token or something so you
could have made a lot of money trading
those tokens but you probably would have
wanted to go to the FTX exchange because
you know guess what news flash it's
illegal in the U.S can I ask you a quick
just a yeah a question about
SPF not so much the inner workings the
mechanics the inner Plumbing of how it
all works just more the person you've
used the word diabolical multiple times
explaining what he's been doing do you
think like he's been compared to Bernie
Madoff Ponzi schemes type of thing Sam
the person do you think he's he's
obviously brilliant and smart and was
able to get away with a lot of stuff but
was he a criminal from the onset did he
just make some foolish mistakes mentally
where was he throughout all this
Sam's he's like the 14 year old kid that
stole the family car he doesn't have a
driver's license he got he got you know
eight of his high school friends in the
car and then he found out that there's
like a hundred thousand dollars of cash
a bunch of drugs and a gun in the car
and then they went George Saturday night
wow you know and
and horrifically with the car wrapped
around a tree half the people but that
analogy I think is very important to
clarify that analogy and maybe he's an
honor student in high school but the
point is he was not ready to drive the
car if he had 30 years of experience if
he was surrounded by 200 Good attorneys
and accountants and and uh banking
credit managers if they if then they
would know what they don't know and
maybe they could have constructed a
company that might have managed this
amount of of risk you're saying he's not
smart enough to have Kant people you're
saying he did that accidentally or it
was intentional like knowing what he's
doing I'm I'm saying that he basically
incompetently foolishly greedily
enthusiastically pursued what he thought
was a good idea but he didn't have the
combination of the real world experience
and the ethics and the legal
understanding and the banking
understanding to even know what he
didn't know so is it criminal absolutely
it's criminal it's like if you if you
roll over a bunch of people in a car and
kill them all it's illegal right but but
at the at the end of the day it's it's
not clear to me that Sam understands
what he did wrong now
like for example what did he do wrong
there's a counting fraud here there's
there's basically Equity fraud by
creating an air token there's all sorts
of credit fraud there's investor fraud
misrepresenting that the equity you sold
the investors they're self-dealing he
issued himself loans there's front
running there's insider trading there's
wash trading there's such a Litany of
ethical and legal lapses but but if you
look at all the coverage in the cryptos
you know World they don't they miss the
fundamental issue which is it's illegal
and unethical to issue your own error
token I mean but that that the entire
premise of the industry an exchange that
trades on registered Securities and an
issuer of unregistered Securities that
fundamentally is unethical everywhere in
the world illegal nearly everywhere in
the world and yet they built the
business on that premise on top up of
that premise
then he inflated the accounting values
built back doors into the into the it's
just non-stop illegal stuff going on
what were you just say Pat yeah here's
what I was going to say so two things
one last night I'm watching a
documentary and let me just I I before I
forget what this documentary was I'm
watching this documentary last night
it's the story of the good nurse the
movie and the documentary came up at the
same time it's a dark documentary I
don't recommend it it's called capturing
the killer nurse I don't know if you've
seen this documentary or not it just
came out so it's a story about a guy
named Charlie Colin or something like
that where he's working out of this just
type in the capturing the killer nurse
and this guy you know intentionally
gives this drug drug to his patients
that they don't track at all in the ICU
and over a 16-year span in this Hospital
in Jersey he kills an estimated 400
people with this shot that he gives and
if you look up what the drug is the drug
is uh Jackson I don't even know how to
pronounce this d-o-d g x i n something
like that okay I've hit images over
there so so he gives us drug and he
kills him and eventually one of his
co-workers like why are all his patients
dying why are so many of his patients
dying and so they eventually gets caught
one of his co-workers Mike's herself
because she's dealing with the FBI and
goes and sits down with him and talking
and she says why are you doing this and
then all of a sudden the mic cuts off
and then there's a live interview of him
and he says well I and he starts crying
he says I'm just doing this because I
didn't know what I was doing I'm just
doing it because I want to put these
people out of their misery and you know
I don't want to experience this pain you
know it's kind of like Sam bankman freed
is like hey today's Wall Street Journal
FTX founder bankman freed said he
couldn't explain what happened to the
billions of dollars that customers of
his failed cryptocurrency exchange sent
to bank accounts of his trading firm
Alameda what do you mean what hap he
doesn't know what happened so to me this
guy knew what he was doing this this guy
behind this afternoon so that he knows
he's killing people and this guy knew
what he was doing so so the part that
this leads me to is two different things
one let's say CR Bitcoin goes to a
hundred let's say Bitcoin doesn't drop
the way it did let's say Bitcoin goes
200 let's say ethereum goes to 6K I'm
just making numbers up right now saying
the theorem goes to 6K Bitcoin goes to
100 000.
does anything happen to them if Bitcoin
goes to 100K and ethereum goes to 6 000.
yes he had created an extremely fragile
situation where he had
he had one account Alameda that had a 10
Billion Dollar Plus margin position
backed by air and if that if that air
token ftt or serum if they had been
attacked by anybody the entire thing
goes up like a house card so so I think
if you look at all the blow-ups right
Celsius block fi dokwon Luna Terra three
arrows Genesis and FTX all of them uh
were were going to blow up at some point
because like uh Luna Terra it was a 20
billion dollars worth of a stable coin
backed by two billion dollars of real
assets and a 50 billion dollar Luna
thing that had 50 million dollars a day
of real liquidity so so they were all
running on 100x rehypothecated Leverage
and they were going to blow up it's just
a question of when they're gonna blow up
I think that this is uh it's a it's a
painful deleveraging of the entire
industry but if you look at everybody
that was kind of Behaving Badly like
doing stupid things like like again
aggressive lending in the real world is
1.4 leverage that's insanely aggressive
lending these guys were all running at
20x 10x that's insane to me so you had a
lot of people Behaving Badly they were
destined to blow up it might have been
held off for a bit but I have seen
pretty credible evidence
circulating in the Twitter sphere that
Alameda had already taken a three to
four billion dollar loss in 2021 during
the bull market because they were just
doing stupid things so how come nobody
caught him then what what was the
Tipping Point was the Tipping Point when
he went to the binance CEO and says hey
uh uh I I need you to you know why don't
we partner up and okay I need a billion
dollars from he said oh yeah we'll do
the deal in the last one no no we're not
doing the deal because even if we buy it
it's just not the interview that he did
which was fascinating by the way the CEO
binance so very impressed by that guy
says no we're not even touching him he
says are you concerned that you're
losing a company like FTX as a
competitor he says he's not a competitor
if you know this business we're not
competitors so what was if you're saying
last year they lost three to four
billion in a in a very bullish Market
what was the Tipping Point all of a
sudden hey we got to get recently got
away with this he's running a private
unregulated cut set of companies right
he had his private holding company paper
bird he had Alameda a private company he
had FTX a private company no
transparency no disclosure if you were
running a public company you got to
actually publish audited financials
every quarter and make 8K statements and
you have adult supervision you I have
lawyers Banker I have two sets of
lawyers two sets of accountants you know
an army of an army of internal
accountants external accountants
Etc and if I just came on your show and
said hey I just wanted to announce that
microstrategy has 175 000 Bitcoin my
phone would start ringing by the lawyers
put that down they'd be like what are
you doing you're crazy yeah and you know
they would say it not just because it's
wrong they would say it because their
careers are on the line and they don't
want to spend 10 years in litigation
hell so there's a way that you run a
public company and there's a way you run
a regulated company and and on the other
hand Sam was his own regulator he could
make up his own rules he had he was
accountable to no one and if you have 10
billion dollars in the bank and then you
lose 4 billion
and you don't and the bank doesn't have
to disclose what is done with the money
you just go and give yourself a four
billion dollar loan secretly you know he
didn't tell anybody so they were able in
essence because they had so much power
as private unregular it's not just
unregulated it's one thing to be
unregulated it's unregulated and opaque
if you if you look at uh and poorly run
right there are some offshore businesses
tether binance that are that are not
regulated and they're not onshore in the
US they're not public but but by Common
wisdom they generally are viewed as
better run like adults adult supervision
because when people ask them to redeem
15 billion dollars they can do it right
I think that FTX three arrows you know
these companies that went bankrupt doe
Quan and Luna they were just really
poorly run opaque crypto organizations
and it was it was destined now the what
was the pen I think
like there was uh there was a summer a
simmering uh a simmering war going on
between the Bitcoin movement and the
crypto movement in DC and the Bitcoin
movement is Satoshi gave us ethical
money nobody controls it you have to pay
for it by burning energy or by buying it
with real cash and you can't corrupt it
you can't issue more it's capped at 21
million nobody gets to you know co-opt
it or use it in a useless fashion to
make themselves Rich okay that's Bitcoin
um the crypto world is you know well we
invented Solana to be better than
Bitcoin and we invented such and such
ftt to be cleaner than Bitcoin and don't
mind the fact that we gave 80 percent of
it to ourself right and that uh and that
we're going to dump the rest of the
general public and we're opaque about it
now that that uh war is going on on
Capitol Hill where the crypto Lobby is
lobbying for light or no regulation let
us basically issue these tokens and make
them Commodities and so we don't have
any Securities laws constraining us
The Regulators that understand better
like a guy like the chair of the SEC
would say look they're all Securities
you can't just let them trade as
Commodities that's the same as saying
anybody can issue their own equity and
and lie cheat and steal the general
public and that would threaten the
entire 100 trillion dollar Securities
Market
but you know Sam you know Sam was the
number two donor the Democratic party he
was the number three donor to the
Republican Party they've admitted to 200
million to 300 million in donations but
they might have donated hundreds of
millions more you're saying that he was
donating that much Republican and we're
very familiar with how much he's donated
to the Democratic party he was I believe
number two but yeah he needs both sides
I tell you his daughter it's diabolical
we know that he was the number two donor
to the Democratic party and until about
a month ago that was the narrative and
then we found out that the chief
operating officer that worked for him
was the number three donor to the
Republican party and and that guy gave
25 million to the Republicans in the
last few weeks so not he himself not
himself because he is fully uh
supportive of what the Democratic
beliefs are look I mean he wanted to be
viewed as remember he said he was going
to give a billion dollars in the next
election cycle yeah he might have given
a billion in the last election cycle we
don't know but he wanted to be viewed as
the as the great uh Progressive Savior
and finance here so they gave they gave
hundreds of millions of dollars to
celebrities they give hundreds of
millions of dollars to academic
institutions hundreds of millions of
dollars to politicians huge amounts of
money to journalists right why wouldn't
you keep in mind if I can generate 10
billion dollars in air token in order to
make a billion a year
all I got to do is take 10 million
dollars lever it up five to one lean on
the liquidity on my own exchange and the
price moves three or four bucks I get
two billion dollars more I made two you
know I made two billion in the year in
investment income and then I go and I
borrow one or two or three or four
billion in my margin account
right they had in that they were
counterfeiting money and then they were
using the counterfeit money to steal
other money or either to steal it from
their deposit or steal it from their
investors or steal it from creditors
then they were funneling that into the
political and the marketing process and
that's why you saw them on the Super
Bowl ad that's why the FTX Arena was
named after them that's why every
celebrity is getting sued right now
right if you can what business is better
than counterfeiting money as a business
right okay so what what burst the bubble
here well this can't go on forever and
and uh in DC there's a war over whether
or not the SEC should regulate crypto or
whether the cftc should regulate crypto
so Sam supports a bill the stabenon
Bozeman Bill and they give huge amounts
of money to politicians and if you read
the bill the bill said crypto will be
regulated by the cftc what's the cftc
the commodity Futures Trading okay we
know what the SEC okay the cftc would
regulate if you were trading soybeans or
pork bellies or Commodities or anything
come on he's got it okay a commodity is
an asset without an issuer okay a
commodity is a much more ethical thing
to promote and to trade than a security
a security
is Yo-Yo coin or or penny stock I
invented it the difference between a
security and a commodity is if I looked
at you right now and said you know I
don't like people in Japan I'm just
going to turn off all their Steel
I can't do that right I can't make steel
not work in Japan I can't turn off
electricity in Japan or turn off oranges
right so a commodity is an asset without
an issuer no matter how much money you
have of pork bellies or Lumber you
cannot invalidate somebody else's Lumber
okay and that's why it's it's impossible
to commit Securities fraud is that
because that's those are natural
resources
these are natural resources pork
everything because they're they're again
it's land right if I said to you buy
land in Texas and I was wrong
okay it's like I'm I didn't create the
land in Texas I can't remove the land in
Texas but what if I said buy Texas coin
there's only a million Texas coins it's
going up and then you buy Texas coin and
then I go and I give myself 10 million
more unlocked Texas coin I dump it on
the market the price goes to zero
now do you feel like you got cheated
you say you see how it's possible to
cheat you with a security because I can
manipulate the characteristics of the
security a security is an asset with an
issuer so if you have an asset with an
issuer like for example a publicly
traded stock like microstrategy mstr is
an asset with an issuer I have ethical
civil obligations right you know if I
lie about it I I can't just say I can't
I'm not going to say what I'm going to
say right I don't even talk about it I
wouldn't I wouldn't tell you to buy it
or not buy it I would say read our
disclosures there's thousand pages of
risk factors
everybody in the board of directors
everything we've done everything we
think we're going to do if we change our
mind about what we're going to do you're
going to read it in 8k within four
business days because I have an
obligation to be transparent on a
security but on the other hand if I say
I really think you ought to stock up on
Lumber in case you know you need to burn
it this winter I'm promoting a commodity
maybe you stock up on Lumber and you
overpay for it maybe you stock up on
Lumber and you don't need it during the
winter right did I defraud you
I'm promoting Lumber maybe I gave you
bad advice but the difference between
promoting Lumber and promoting
lumbercoin is I can print a hundred
trillion Lumber coin
you know on Saturday night and dump it
on you and drive your Lumber coin to
zero I can't create a hundred trillion
Forest overnight by snapping my fingers
it's a natural phenomenon it doesn't
that speak to just a bigger question
about the crypto Market in general like
a lot of people will be like yeah I
don't you know I can't touch it I can't
hold it even with nfts meaning real
estate I can hold it I can touch it
Commodities cash these are tangible
assets even the stock market however
with crypto it's it's all very digital
you can't touch it I feel like a lot of
people are uncomfortable with that yeah
it gets to the fundamental point of what
are those assets some of those assets
are crypto Commodities a crypto
commodity is a token without an issuer
that cannot be manipulated by some CEO
or Corporation or other party right
there are crypto currencies like tether
and circle they are actually tokens
meant to represent the US dollar or some
other stable asset they have an issuer
and generally they're going to be
regulated as as Securities and as
currencies by the banking establishment
the SEC then there's crypto securities
Solana ftt serum those were all
Securities they had an issuer there were
companies behind them there were CEOs
behind them people could make more of
them people can destroy them there are
some people insiders that had
disproportionate interest in them those
could only be ethically sold to the
general public pursuant to a full and
fair disclosure
right and this is common sense right if
you create something and you dump it on
the general population you have an
ethical obligation to tell them who made
the decision how much is there you know
what is your background what's going to
happen next that's what you do when you
take company public
so coming coming back to this crypto
issue you had a little war between
between the two factions and the right
answer is if you're selling a crypto
security
it should be regulated by the SEC
if you have a crypto commodity then it's
not a security now the question is
what's a crypto commodity the chair of
the SEC has said the only crypto asset
that's clearly a commodity is Bitcoin
the chair of the cftc had said as of a
few months ago the only crypto assets
that are Commodities or Bitcoin and
ether
but ethereum is not really a commodity
ethereum is a security and that has been
a big fight in the community
below the surface as of last Wednesday
the chair of the cftc went to Princeton
gave a speech and said the only crypto
asset which I deem is commodity is
Bitcoin so now you have the cftc and the
SEC
and and certain other Regulators that
had a treasury the head of the Federal
Reserve you know all of them in essence
endorsing Bitcoin as a commodity
and leaving us to figure out what we're
going to do with the Securities and the
currencies that exist in the system
the thing that brought FTX Crashing Down
is that Sam went to DC spent a lot of
money on lobbyists lobbied for this bill
that would have made uh both Bitcoin and
ethereum commodities and would have put
the cftc in control would have created
light regulation would have created a
path for other crypto tokens to be
viewed as Commodities and in addition to
like giving a lot of money to the media
a lot of money to the academics a lot of
money to the politicians and a lot of
money to the celebrities he also
inserted in the bill that that uh the
crypto exchanges would send fees to the
cftc and they in essence try to bribe
the cftc with with crypto usage fees in
order to get light regulation
that didn't go over well with a whole
set of regulators that thought that that
was a way to undermine the Securities
industry it was at a deadlock that's why
we haven't had any uh regulation because
of this deadlock between I think people
that know better
and
look to crypto people have they had
billions of dollars of counterfeit money
Sam just Sam alone spent billions of
dollars of counterfeit stolen money but
imagine if everybody that was generating
crypto tokens doing the same thing right
now and I'm I'm not going to go into the
into the others involved but you can
probably figure out what's going on
you have a lot of money trying to get a
very light regulatory regime
uh wide sand blow up well Sam went to DC
and in addition to trying to get you
know fairly exceptional treatment just
for his exchange he then started bad
mouthing binance and and uh implying
that uh the other offshore exchanges
were much shadier than his
and uh that pissed them off and that
pissed off CZ
and so CZ said okay well and that
combined with
combined with the leak of the balance
sheet when the Alameda balance sheet
leaked and it was clear that something
like 10
12 billion dollars of 14 billion in
assets were air tokens backed by nothing
it became pretty clear that they were
rickety imagine if I said I have 12
billion dollars of air token it trades
10 million dollars a day
okay well all you got to do is dump 100
million dollars on the market it's going
to zero so once they saw that I think CZ
has decided the heavyweight the CZ the
heavyweight of heavy weights or would
you put uh yeah
look look off that's the CEO of Finance
yes off sure right offshore the most
influential uh person in the industry a
CZ but worldwide
I think the most influential person in
the industry is the chair of the SEC and
the entire yeah Gary guns are and the
entire industry
pretty much is waiting to see what
Gensler will do and Gensler is is pretty
much the one person who could provide a
Playbook a set of rules of the road that
would cause this industry to move
forward in an economically responsible
ethical fashion this this guy is not a
light guy he he's he's a guy that some
people are in the middle are careful on
what to say about them because they know
they need them some people are very
careful to see if you push too much he
may over regulate you he may take
because he's got a lot of power he's
like Gary Gensler this guy's a very
powerful person in America yeah you
brought up drone palsy bigger than power
no he's not big I don't know if he's big
no he's not bigger than power Powell
maybe shamat says Powell maybe the most
powerful man uh because he controls Wars
if the interest rates go high you can't
finance a war but what are your thoughts
about what he's doing with ripple the
Ripple Army I had John D Eaton here the
lawyer representing Ripple what are your
thoughts about what's going on with
ripple and how he is handling the real
case Ripple is an unregistered security
it's pretty obvious there's a company
the company owns a bunch of it they sell
it to the general public but there's no
they never took the company public
there's no disclosures
right so so the sec's position is you're
selling an unregistered security it's a
it's a crypto token right just like
ethereum it's a non-registered security
it's controlled by a few people in the
ethereum foundation and consensus
ftt just like Salon perfect but here's a
follow-up they're all unregistered
secured here's a follow-up on that I
don't own a single Ripple just so we
know so full disclaimer I'm not a ripple
guy but if if both of them are
unregistered why Target Ripple and not
Target ethereum the way he is targeting
Ripple
and by the way this is coming from a guy
that owns uh ethereum not Ripple yeah I
think I think the best thing for the
world would be with the if the SEC
pretty much shut down all of it
it's all unethical right I mean the
Bitcoin position would be
Bitcoin is an ethical commodity all of
these other altcoins are unregistered
Securities they're all just Equity
tokens issued by a company in order to
get around going public and they're
committing Securities fraud ethereum
included of course especially ethereum
you know ethereum's got 20 billion
dollars of each token locked up in the
staking contract right now and there's a
couple of people that may or may not
give it back to you ever
Now isn't that the definition of
investment contract if if a bank took 20
billion dollars of your assets froze the
the window and said you can't have your
money back ever maybe in the year 2024
we're not sure we're just going to keep
it we may actually give you interest on
it we may take it all we may you know we
may slash it
that's the definition of a security
right it's an investment of money in a
common Enterprise you know relying upon
the efforts of others an expectation of
profit
the whole the whole point is if you want
a crypto asset to be a commodity you
can't rely upon four Engineers a company
a CEO if if a person can make a decision
it's not a commodity anymore the fact is
Ripple's got a company ethereum's got a
company ethereum Foundation has
Engineers you're literally waiting on
the engineers that work for the ethereum
foundation to write the code to give you
your money back and then you're also
waiting to find out what the monetary
policy will be
they change it half a dozen times in the
last six years it's always changing to
you it's xrp and ripple the same thing
there are both on registered securities
xrp and yeah xrp is just the equity
token of Ripple
yeah
so I mean it seems quite obvious right
if you wanna if you want a road map for
how you create a commodity you have to
do it the way Satoshi did it you create
a protocol
you give it to the world you disclaim
beneficial ownership of it you disclaim
control of it and you disappear
that's what Satoshi did it was a gift to
the world if the founder is still around
and the founder is a billionaire and the
founder is spending hundreds of millions
or billions of dollars to defend the
token isn't it obvious that it's a
software company with an equity
so I I think that that's pretty evident
with all these crypto tokens what you
have is you have
the complete sham Ponzi schemes you know
like at the collapse in a hurry like
Terra Luna then you have crypto tokens
that are unregistered Securities that
are perhaps somewhat pseudo-competently
managed that don't collapse but they're
still unregistered Securities which
makes them unethical to promote
and then you have crypto currencies like
tether and circle they attempt to have
backing right Circle purports have a
hundred percent backing uh for their
coin we know that to like 83 percent of
tether deposits are backed by U.S
treasuries if you're to believe their
attestations
but again those
those are not publicly traded companies
so I think the one thing that's missing
in the crypto industry is by and large
nearly everybody in the crypto Market
has never taken a company public they
don't understand Security's law they're
like if you're going to be kind you're
going to say they're well-meaning
technologists that are enthusiastically
pursuing new ideas
but generally they're pursuing new ideas
in an irresponsible
inappropriate unethical fashion is that
based on Greed what is that based on
the same reason Sam did it is a one-part
greed one part enthusiasm go fast and
break things one part lack of adult
supervision
right uh what you what
what you could say is that
that
um you know the The Regulators ought to
just be very very clear if you were very
clear you'd say look
you've got like 180 days in order to
register your token with the SEC and you
register and give us all fill out these
forms give us all these facts answer our
questions and we'll tell you whether
you're a currency whether or not you're
a commodity whether or not your security
and whether or not you're allowed to
trade and at the end of the 180 days if
you haven't actually registered you're
shut down and nobody can buy and sell
and trade this thing anywhere in the
world and that that would actually clean
up the industry in a hurry
I got a crazy question for you can you
pull up the article that I sent you a
bunch of Articles while we're talking
pull up the one about Maxine uh her
tweet uh if you can pull up vaccine
Waters here's her tweet that just came
out we appreciate SPF uh sambang my
friend we appreciate that you've been
candid in your discussions about what
happened at FTX your willingness to talk
to the public with the will help the
company's customers investors and others
to the end uh to that end we would
welcome your participation in our
hearing on the 13th wow she speaks more
respectfully to a young kid than she
does to a former president which is
interesting how her style of
communication but you know I will tell
you this so you know how the story just
came out with Twitter and Hunter Biden
okay and uh uh Talib italyby that is the
one that put the Tweet out there was a
whole five and a half no no no no
yeah there was a Twitter live yesterday
hosted by omario he invited me on myself
Elon and Jordan Peters there was like
eight of us that were supposed to be on
I was on a freaking flight back I missed
call but I heard everybody has to listen
to it if you haven't heard it that's
when Elon Musk confirmed I have no
desire to commit suicide the question
was asked which was kind of interesting
but there was a part there was a part
where he talked about he certainly has
to be uh protecting himself because he
wouldn't be surprised his life is at
risk in other words kind of the way he
put it
so the more and more these guys go
through the emails and they find out
what how the Twitter Executives were
communicating with the Biden
Administration on what stories to post
and what stories not to post and how he
was colluding and all this other stuff
and some people are now saying well at
the time when he was colluding he wasn't
a president these stories that are
spinning and then you hear a story that
comes out uh that three crypto
billionaires died I don't know if you
saw that one or not if you want to pull
that up go a little lower zoom in and go
a little lower three crypto bosses died
in recent weeks I think these guys were
all uh billionaires uh Nikolai musherian
29 years old Tian Tian kulander 30 years
old and Via cheslav turn around 53 years
old all of a sudden they all die within
a week it's kind of weird you know what
country is there from I mean it's all
over the place one is Russia you know
anyways you can kind of see where these
stories uh are coming from
Russian entrepreneurs are one of them
you know the causes of vets are
helicopter stay at the top see at the
top I was reading at helicopter crash
while sleeping and drowning kind of
weird helicopter crash while sleeping
and drowning those are the three
different those are the three which kind
of that's a little little weird
and then yeah so so this is kind of
weird now here's the part
um
some of these guys who know a lot if
they know I don't know if you've seen
the story or not if not I can read it
for you uh uh Michael if you're not
following it so the 50 or 30 year old
Russian is the third cryptocurrency boss
to be found dead under his mysterious
circumstances after helicopter Crush in
your Monaco indeed it appears at the
crash occurred in good weather
conditions and after another passenger
allegedly canceled the flight last
minute thus raising suspicions
for these very reasons the deputy
prosecuted from nice who visited the
scene said that the fault of a third
party cannot be ruled out Terran
co-founded the training and investment
platform libertex and Forex club and was
flying from Lao Zane with an experienced
pilot in a single engine h-130
helicopter when it crashed around 1 pm
on 25th of November to 35 year French
pilot was also killed anyways we can go
on with all these stories so here's the
part so you're seeing how Maxine Waters
and many of these folks he had an event
with Bill Clinton he had an event with a
lot of these guys they're being
extremely extremely respectful to this
SPF guy now as a street person who grew
up watching Power plays and different
kind of things being done and who
respect the two for what motives they're
being very careful with this guy does he
know some things that they want they
don't want people to know about is there
some speculation there these three
bosses on the crypto side that are going
there's a lot of conspiracy stories
theories that you're hearing about just
a lot of weird things going on in your
space okay do you have any commentary on
everything I just said here
yeah well uh helicopters are dangerous
that's my first car
you know probably 10 to 20 acts more
dangerous than traveling in an airplane
and uh you know Kobe
you know died in a helicopter lots of
people die in helicopters so so uh
that's tragic if it's just a helicopter
rack there's a war in Ukraine there's
there's Russians ukrainians are are
caught in a life and death struggle and
so there's a difference is if LeBron
Kobe and Michael died the same week it's
a little weird no I'm agreeing with you
if if you're a Russian with access to a
huge amounts of amount of money moving
freely through Europe in the middle of a
in a time period when there's a war
between Ukraine and Russia
right you got to wonder what money was
moving to whom and and right maybe so I
asked what country maybe maybe you
stiffed the wrong person I don't know uh
but I you know I don't have any insight
one way the other what I'd say
what I'd say is uh you know be careful
around helicopters that's my first thing
I'd say
second you know it's not it's not easy
in Europe right now for a Ukrainian or a
Russian right I don't it's not easy for
anybody especially for for someone in
the middle of a war it's tough time
third
third I think everybody wants to
interview Sam because Sam's the big get
and if you can get him in front of your
committee you get all the TV cameras on
you it's a huge media you know score and
uh it's not very often that someone that
stole 10 billion dollars is willing to
give interviews right uh you know and my
my thought about that is it's obvious he
you know he stole billions from
creditors he stole billion from
investors he stole billions from
depositors you know uh they're gonna do
five movies probably three TV shows four
books and there's going to be a thousand
lawsuits and you're gonna be reading
about this horrific findings for the
next five years on this thing
you know and it may take years and years
for them to sort out everything that
happened
and uh so it's not surprising to me that
the oils of Justice would move slowly
just because it's so complicated
but if you're in the industry and you
have a modicum of Common Sense and some
you know life experience you look at it
and you say what happened well
it's pretty obvious what happened it's
kind of like they got high on on free
money you know I created a 100 million
dollar token it became a billion dollar
token that I could borrow against it
holy crap I could borrow two billion
dollars against a billion dollar token
if you could borrow two billion dollars
against a billion dollar error token and
it only cost 10 million dollars a day to
get your air token to double in value
wouldn't you be tempted to recycle the
money you borrowed back into the money
you counterfeited so it just got to be
too easy and once they got to that point
right they go from nothing to he's he's
worth nothing in 2018 or 2019 to being
worth 20 billion dollars now now you've
got politicians you've got Clinton
you've got you know Tony Blair you've
got everybody in the world wants to talk
to me I'm on the front cover of every
magazine
you know it goes to your head and then
you just want to go harder and then at
some point you start to embellish and
cut Corners this way in that way and and
it's
it's like if you're going you know speed
kills
you start going fast enough at some
point you're going 180 miles an hour
down a highway and then you decide to
take a rocky road and you fly off the
side of the road and everything is just
fine until you go off the road then you
look down your eyes it's a 500 foot drop
and you're going 180 miles an hour at
that point you're going to go up in a
ball of flame you can't pull it back now
you know at what point did it happen
isn't it the human condition that like
young men with a huge amount of power
you know Let it go to their head and
then they'd overdrive the car and then
they wreck it where does this yeah but
but there's a problem here I mean the
difference is you're hoping that young
kid or young man was raised properly to
not be able to do things like this we
know what his mother wrote in 2013 in a
paper as a professor of Stanford I don't
know if you saw this one where Sam
bankman Freed's a professor mother pent
2013 essay shredding philosophy of
personal responsibility which a a kid
raised with a mother mother who doesn't
believe in personal responsibility would
do something like that and say who cares
but I'm not that that's not even my
concern my concern is the following
here's my concern you're a very sharp
guy very my uh uh understanding of
crypto changed I sat with a lot of
different people until I sat with you
your way of teaching you'd be the kind
of a teacher I can sit there and listen
to because the way you explain is it
works for me maybe not for others I like
your style of teaching and explaining so
you know for for somebody to be used you
know the other day they had Ari flasher
here I don't know if you remember Ari
Fleischer was a former press secretary
for President Bush from 01 until 2004 at
the peak of 9 11 when all that mess has
taken place imagine that job every day
you're answering all these different
questions that you have to answer about
what happened who was behind it you know
all this other stuff and then story came
about a CIA agent on CIA director of CIA
George tenant that George Bush kept
Clinton's CI agent director of CIA
George Tenet and he was the one that
walked into the room and told President
Bush Rumsfeld everybody and said hey
there is what was the word use without a
shadow of a doubt they have weapons of
mass destruction there and President
Bush went on his Intel to say if they do
then we got to do what we got to do here
right it's kind of like Adam Schiff
coming out and saying without a shadow
of doubt there's collusion with Russia
on the right okay
so then I said
okay who are the who are the ones that
are simply using President Bush would a
Donald Rumsfeld if you've seen a movie
Vice use President Bush to make money
stocks all this other stuff because of
you know
the military equipment being sold and it
was a great business model etc etc okay
maybe so in this case because I don't
trust George Tennant giving counsel to
the president and he was representing
you know President Clinton he would he
the only two presidents that chose the
prior director of CIA one was President
Bush the other one was John F Kennedy
right they used the same one as a prior
one do you think
this guy right here our friend uh Sam
bankman freed is you being used as a
puppet to protect them and there's a lot
of paper trail behind closed doors that
if people really found what he was doing
others knew that this guy was doing
Shady business but they were protecting
him because a lot of money was coming in
do you think there's there could be any
of that coming out or no it's just a guy
that was extremely smart found a way to
make money and his passion because of
his mom was to give a bunch of money to
the Democratic party to make the biggest
advancement for Progressive philosophies
I mean I think he gave a lot of people a
lot of money and so it's a bit
embarrassing
to a lot of people that they all took
his money and then I think there's this
question of will they give it back
the fascinating thing here is is is
every organization is the is the media
the academics and the politicians are
they all going to give the money back to
the bankruptcy trustee to go to the
depositors or not which is the right
thing to do or not so I think you know
it if um if you just got a lot of money
from from someone and then you find out
that they stole it
you know if if the message is they stole
the money then that's a fraudulent
conveyance and and you were paid off
with stolen money maybe you got to give
it back that's a challenge so I think
that a lot of people are going to be
slow to come to that conclusion because
they've got a conflict of interest but I
I don't think he's going to get away
with it I think that the wheels of
Justice are slow but they do grind
forward and it's just so many smoking
guns here you can't very well steal
15 billion to 20 billion dollars from so
many different constituencies
uh and uh and not be held responsible
for it at some point in time they're
just going to play with him in the media
as long as he gives these interviews and
as long as he's willing to show up a lot
a lot of people are going to indulge him
but you know like what should happen he
should be arrested right now I was just
going to ask you that you you use that
the analogy that many movies are going
to be made about Sam bakeman freed so
how does this movie End you know we
talked about personal responsibility and
being held accountable do you think he's
going to see jail time should he see
jail time what kind of sentence should
he be facing
he saw billions and billions of dollars
from innocent people yeah he should he
should be in jail a long time really
a lot of people think that he's never
going to see jail ever
you know I took three years I think I
read uh before they brought charges in
the Enron case
okay so Twitter Twitter is a high a fast
twitch response system where somebody
posts something and five minutes later
everybody is uh indignant if you haven't
uh come to a conclusion yes or no
but you know when you're building a case
or a complex Financial case if you were
to build it in in two months or four
months it would be light speed for
complicated Financial cases
so I I think that Justice will arrive
and I I think it's pretty obvious
again as I said every type of fraud
imaginable that the complication
is half the frauds
like the Securities fraud and and the
like half the frauds are are harder to
assert because he was an offshore
jurisdiction
you know like Sam wouldn't have actually
gotten this big if he had been operating
in New York City under the U.S law
because nothing that he did is legal you
can't it's not legal to issue a token
it's not legal to trade against your
customers it's not legal to give 20x
leverage it's not legal to you know to
trade without a license you know so so
he he couldn't have gotten there in a
mature environment and a rule of law
you know he he went to a sunny place for
shady people maybe like they they
literally searched every jurisdiction in
the world I mean he wasn't he was in
Hong Kong and it was illegal to do what
he was doing in Hong Kong they were
Singapore it was illegal to do what he's
doing in Singapore they just tripped
every which way it would be illegal to
do anything that they were doing in
Europe it's illegal to do anything that
they're doing you have to assume
that it was pretty much illegal to do
anything that he was doing anywhere
except for a small handful of places and
then even given that
the stuff he agreed he disclosed that he
was doing is only half of what he was
doing the other half of the stuff that
he didn't disclose that was not legal in
the Bahamas either this Pat's initial
question I think is
is very valuable about do you think he
would have got caught if Bitcoin would
have kept going and the crypto Market
would have kept going up to a hundred
thousand like what's the famous phrase
he would have been he would have been
caught because he was counterfeiting
money and then he was recklessly
pledging it in order to borrow more
money and spending it but would have
taken decades like you know the famous
phrase Like Only When the tide goes out
you discover who's swimming naked Like
Bernie Madoff the greatest Ponzi schemer
ever he was operating for decades
decades decades and it was only until
2008 the financial collapse and there
was Bank runs people needed money did
finally his Ponzi scheme get exposed so
meaning of crypto would have kept going
and going and going could it possibly
have been decades before Sam begman
fried and FDX Works no because they were
too Reckless I mean Madoff was extremely
buttoned down controlled
right a very deliberate and actually in
the greater scheme of things
conservative for you know Madoff didn't
put his name on a stadium he didn't
Splash it did Madoff give a billion
dollars to politicians did Madoff ever
put a press where he's saying I'm going
to give what happens when a person with
no money 24 months ago puts out a press
release saying I'm going to give a
billion dollars to the Democrats in the
next two years good point you don't
think his head down wasn't looking for
headlines but SPF was searching for
headlines but if you listen to people
that talk about how they came into
Nassau you know guns are blazing so he
came in he bought every piece of real
estate you know they said well you know
here's this Penthouse they want 40 offer
them 32 so it doesn't matter surrounding
error give them 36 or get whatever he
was just splashing money around like it
was free no but Michael you're in the
crypto world right bat and I are I mean
maybe we own some Bitcoin ethereum yeah
but I feel like
and rightfully so there's a lot of
Monday Morning Quarterback about
Sam begman freed and FTX well it turns
out illegal turns out this were their
stories circulating a year ago two years
ago
during all the fraud not the aftermath
look the stuff the stuff in the domain a
year ago was
Sam makes 10 million a week at Alameda
Alameda is a money machine that
generates 10 million a week or 500
million a year and that's his cash cow
and and the exchange is just the
exchange and and then people couldn't
quite figure out the rest except for the
fact that obvious you know all these
tokens are air tokens that are being
manipulated offshore right so so the the
belief was they were good Traders and
they were manipulating air tokens and
running an unregulated exchange
the truth of course that comes out now
is they weren't good Traders they were
goofballs and really the the machine
that made this all work
the Brilliance of it is to generate 10
billion dollars worth of fake collateral
and then borrow 10 billion dollars
that's crazy to me well I mean three
things I generate 10 billion in fake
collateral I take 10 billion of money
out of my bank from my real customers I
show fake fraudulent accounting
statements to investors and get them to
give me billions more
and then I pledge the token collateral
to other crypto hedge funds and get them
to give me billions of loans so so you
could say that last part that was you
know was I I took advantage of some
other crypto Bros that were also a bit
Yeah a bit uh what is it uh
risk addicted like uh you know too
aggressive and I took advantage of
venture capitalists that threw caution
of the wind that weren't paying
attention
but and the first part is you know I
attracted all those billions by just
telling people I'll give them extreme
leverage and let them trade these tokens
and make it cheap
and then I I again there are these
diabolical twists where Sam would uh he
would like buy block fi and then and
then pressure them to put their assets
on his exchange and so a lot or he
bought a lot of things and when he
bought the things he would pressure the
people
to put their Assets in TR on his
exchange or trade with him so
I'm issuing Equity like the equity in
FTX you know was worth I mean Sam would
say oh it's a 32 billion dollar
valuation you remember reading that and
Forbes and Fortune okay I've got a 32
billion dollar company I'm going to give
you a billion dollars worth of ft x
equity and then I've got my shadow
Equity eight ten billion dollars worth
of ftt at one point ftt was worth 15
billion dollars so so they generated
these two Equity tokens the people that
are based on what uh opaque financials
that are fraudulent right if I if I have
fraudulent financials and I I crank up
the two Equity tokens then I can use
them to do Acquisitions you're rolling
the entire thing forward
so I it was
I guess my point here is
if you're doing that and you're
extracting five billion dollars of real
cash and then you're buying he put a
billion into a Bitcoin miner he put a
billion into marketing he bought a
billion worth of other stuff if you're
actually extracting real cash you're
burning the candle at both ends
and so it was destined to blow up
because they were just too aggressive
just like with Terra Luna you know Terra
UST was a stable coin when it was a
couple billion dollars and Luna was a
few billion more
it's like a six eight billion dollar
unstable thing but what blew it up was
when do Quan decided he wanted to offer
20 yield on UST and he took that two
billion dollar stable coin to be worth
almost 20 billion now you've got 20
billion dollars and then Luna became
worth 60 billion or 50 billion so you've
got like this 65 70 billion dollar
complex getting big too fast
it's like I borrowed if I borrowed 20
billion dollars and I agreed to pay you
20 interest
I have to come up with four billion
dollars a year in real cash to roll that
forward and if I'm printing my own
Equity token to pay the 4 billion
eventually that Equity token crashes
because it gets diluted in the market
the entire thing just goes to zero so
going fast
on a Ponzi scheme cause it to blow up
Bernie Madoff went slow
and that's why he was able to roll and
end and he didn't you know he didn't uh
wave a red flag
at the bowl right I mean Sam was was
going hard he was basically attacking
the entire Bitcoin Community by by under
supporting all this ESG BS about using
electricity he was also attacking the
other crypto exchanges like binance he
was also going head-to-head with the SEC
those are three powerful sets of enemies
you know while you're going 180 miles an
hour do you think he knew he was going
to get caught at some point no I think
he was I really you think he's doing all
this illegal stuff you use the 14 year
old kid who's told the parents car
analogy with the drugs and the gun in
the back he's doing all this he's
defrauding people investors consumers
he's doing all this stuff all this
illegal stuff with Bahamas yeah Left
Right illegal illegal and you generally
think he didn't think he would ever get
caught he's delusional no regret I'd say
he's delusion like a week after he blew
the entire thing up he was thinking he
could just make a phone call and raise
10 billion dollars in order to save it I
he's going to process this for the next
two three four years and you know many
years from now he'll he may look back if
he's honest with himself and figure out
what he did I I think he's just deluding
himself you know it's like these stories
we tell ourselves that if we tell them
we tell these like for example if you
listen to Sam's language he doesn't say
okay
I stole 10 billion dollars from my
customers and I used FTX like my
personal piggy bank and I gave it to
Alameda and then Alameda gave 4 billion
of it to me and then I spent it on stuff
he doesn't say that he says I didn't
realize that Alameda had a margin
position it was a little bit bigger than
I thought it was and we had a little bit
of messy account I didn't realize I
marked it up six billion dollars and
took the money he's like our accounting
was messy and our margin position was a
bit larger than I I understood he
doesn't say I counterfeited 14 billion
dollars worth of air tokens he doesn't
say that he says well we had 14 billion
in assets but we just didn't have the
liquidity at the time we needed the
liquid if we had more liquidity then we
could have met these particular demands
and it would have all been fine so
living in this world of liquidity and
margin is a way it's a way for you to
say you don't have to say my customers
put 10 billion dollars in my bank and I
took it and lost it and spent it he just
says my customers had margin positions I
had margin positions it was all
everybody in my arms was a little bit
bigger
now he still hasn't come kind of
admitted or fessed up to this fact that
he had god mode
and there was no way for Alameda to be
liquidated everybody was God mode in
your mind what it means is is you put
Untouchable no no accountability do
whatever you want playing God no it's
like it's like I run a casino everybody
comes in the casino and you roll the
dice and if you lose you lose your chips
but but my son is able to bet infinite
money and if he loses he can double down
with infinite money and he can keep and
he never has to pay it off and so
there's one player in the casino that
never loses only when and can always
Double Down always fun and so the result
is Sam set up a casino everybody else
was subject to being liquidated and
Alameda had this God mode where they
could bet and they could withdraw any
amount of money and they could bet and
if and they would never be liquidated so
what that means is over time Alameda
ended up with a 10 billion dollar debit
there was 10 million credited to the
rest of the players when Alameda went to
a 15 billion dollar debit right and
everything collapses and he's he still
hasn't kind of come to grips with the
fact that that's unethical Michael but
but to have that kind of confidence for
you to ask the question did he know he
was going to get caught there's a part
of me that agrees with Michael there's a
part of me that agrees with you because
to Michael is like yeah you know he uh
uh didn't think he was going to get
caught you're saying he eventually was
going to get caught he knew it right but
to me
when you give money to lobbyists
somebody has to say don't worry about it
I got your back don't worry about it we
got your back keep going nothing's going
to happen to you to play that Reckless
where you believe I'm nothing's really
going to happen to you we got you
whether that's lobbyists whether that's
politicians whether that's whoever you
you have to realize the ripple effect
not to say Ripple like sorry but the
ripple effect of an FTX going down how
many YouTube channels were doing
sponsorships about crypto we got calls
from every single crypto company to for
us to do sponsorships we said no to
every single one of them because it's
too it's too you know you got to be
careful taking that kind of money
because you don't know the stability is
not there yet but how many YouTubers
were making oh making 20 grand a month
sponsorship from FTX we go to meetings
one time you and I were with somebody
it's like oh yeah you would be amazed
crypto companies are throwing money at
us
so anyway so you have those guys you
have scary muchi you have Kevin O'Leary
you have all these athletes you got
names you got celebrities you got FTX
Arena I think got 135 I don't know the
exact number but it was the largest
number that they got you know all of
these people you were talking about the
nightclubs Miami if you want to bring
out what's going on with my story there
well we both live in Miami so this is a
story that's near and dear in my heart
but obviously FTX sponsored the Miami
Heat arena formerly known as American
Airlines love it but you know there's a
story out there in the financial times
that here it is Miami nightclubs mourn
the absence of High rolling crypto
entrepreneurs so they started
interviewing
um people I know friends of mine who run
Groot Hospitality Dave grotman's um
nightlife
place and then also the everyone over at
11 right and I think the Gino lopinto
was who runs 11 he says last year's six
million dollars was spent in crypto this
year it's down to 10K so the Ripple
effects is what you're asking wait wait
you got to say that slower yes 11
started accepting payments in crypto in
April of 2021 the club processed more
than six million dollars of transaction
in 2021 but in the past three months the
club is only processed less than ten
thousand right holy moly so Michael you
got to go up a lot of money enough
lately two two thoughts right first of
all he bought everybody
and how to okay and and let me just make
a stark observation
he counterfeited 10 billion dollars in
one year
if you could counterfeit if you know if
you created 10 it's look you have a 300
million ftt tokens move the price 30
bucks do the math
right thirty dollars on a token when you
give yourself 300 million of them is 10
billion and that's just one token so if
you fall off the turnip truck and you
find that you can generate 10 billion
dollars in a year what do you do you go
buy everybody you buy every influencer
you buy every politician you buy every
celebrity you buy the stadium you buy
all of Albany you buy the government you
buy the everything that's for sale
right it's hard to find a crypto
influencer that didn't take FTX money
but he hired everybody go as fast as you
can how much can you spend a billion in
a year two billion a year they thought
they had found the Fountain of money
right there is nothing more lucrative
than a license to print money this is
why the Bitcoin Maximus just get so
angry right they declare war on the [ __ ]
coiners and [ __ ] coinery the idea that
you can just create your own token sell
it to the general public and manipulate
the price of it and dump it on but but
here's where the poor Bitcoin has never
figured out their view is they're
creating a [ __ ] coin and dumping it on
retail but again Sam's Twist on it was
no I'm not going to dump it on retail
I'm driving into the sky I'm never gonna
sell it I'm going to use it to buy other
Banks and then I'm going to drain the
assets out of the bank by giving myself
an under the table loan it's so much
more diabolical than just dumping a [ __ ]
coin on unsuspect acting retail Traders
so yeah he did it he you know and he
invited that scrutiny and and uh it was
inevitable he reminds me of one other
person by the way if you if you want to
know the antecedent ten years before Sam
bankman freed came along yeah who's that
Jolo
cholo cholo uh if you talk to these same
club guys
not JLo Jolo how do you spell that yeah
a billion dollar whale I I guess was uh
like Jolo
set I'll check out one MDB Scandal one
MDB Jolo how do you spell Jolo Michael
j-o-l-o just like Jolo okay so here's
what Malaysia yeah who this is what
happened
27 year old guy
comes all of a sudden hooks up in a
relationship with the prime minister of
Malaysia convinces the Prime Minister
that they should set up a sovereign
wealth fund and they're going to raise
money and invest it for the good of the
Malaysian people was the Malaysian uh
president a male or female male so
they're gay lovers no no
uh he it's all Resident was the Prime
Minister and najib was in cahoots with
cholo uh and uh Jolo ended up raising 14
billion dollars and the way he raised it
was he he sold fraudulent bonds
they took the money and of course none
of the money found its way to the
Malaysian people Jolo just took it and
stole it and spent it at 1.700 million
was wired into the prime minister's
personal account 50 million dollars
worth of diamonds and shoes got bought
by the Prime Minister for for his wife
on a weekend The Wolf of Wall Street the
entire movie was financed by Jolo
right there there he is at The Wolf of
Wall Street Premiere it looks like it's
very famous the great get out of here
okay that entire movie cost more than
100 million bucks it was paid for with
money stolen from the Malaysian people
Jolo wanted to be a movie star cholo
cholo dated starlets he uh he bought
multi 100 million dollar yachts he would
spend five million dollars a night in
clubs he would come down here to the
Miami nightclubs I wish I ran into them
yeah and uh Jolo
j-h-o-l-o-w two words Joe Lowe and
here's the point the guy would he would
walk into an eye club and he would spend
uh
four million dollars he would buy a
hundred two thousand dollar bottles of
champagne like that spray it everywhere
by a hundred dollar hundred more of them
and people said how can this guy spend a
million a night or two million a night
or the like
and the answer is she stole the money
hey he stole billions and billions of
dollars and he spent it like he stole it
if you made 20 billion dollars you
wouldn't spend money like that right any
event he's a fugitive internationally
but he but before
um
Sam came along and the entire crypto
thing blew up it was this massive
Sovereign wealth Scandal and uh and
there are lots of colorful stories yeah
you bring up such a good point with this
wasteful spending because anybody that
legitimately makes money knows how hard
it is to make money Kevin O'Leary talks
about if I forget to claim my air miles
like I'll go back and call the airlines
because I know what it takes to get the
amount of money to do this but these
people that fraudulently just come up
with money they'll gladly Make It Rain
millions of dollars because it's it's
fake it just came too fast yeah too fast
who's the next SBF how many more spfs
are out there that we don't know about
or maybe nowadays hopefully we're
running out of them
right I mean if we look at this entire
thing right it reached its peak Peak was
you know Terra Luna is worth 70 billion
dollars
and you know do Quan and a couple of
people are all of a sudden the whales
and I think the you know the bubble
popped on the cycle when the FED started
raising interest rates to your point
your own Palace the most powerful person
because he sets the price of money for
500 trillion dollars worth of assets so
that's a pretty powerful job when they
they took these short-term rates you
know from six basis points up to 470
basis points on the one year in 12
months and so when the FED started
tightening that put pressure the first
thing to break was the most fragile
thing which was a poorly engineered
unstable coin called Terra Luna
that brought down three arrows three
arrows crashed and and brought down uh
Celsius and and Voyager and block Phi
and and it fatally wounded uh Alameda
and maybe we'll see what happens with
Genesis but it definitely fatally
wounded a lot of other players but it
wasn't obvious
and the reason it's not obvious again is
to make make this point is publicly
traded companies have a fiduciary
obligation to disclose transparently
within four business days or less on an
8K
like if if my CFO said guess what we
just did something stupid and we lost a
billion dollars I don't sit on that for
a year I don't sit on that for a quarter
like some number of hours at 9 30 a.m on
Monday when the market starts trading
people are trading my stock and if I
have material information that a
rational investor would think is
material to their buying or selling the
stock I have an ethical and a legal
obligation to disclose it and it's
pretty obvious why I mean if you were on
the other side of the trade I would want
to know yeah so it's Celsius Celsius
went and they they barred 500 million
dollars from you know I think Equity
first or something uh and uh and when
they return the money they didn't get
their collateral back and they got you
know somehow they made a they borrowed
money and then their creditor kept their
collateral and they lost half a billion
dollars
but they didn't disclose it to anybody
for a year they just kind of went on and
they raised more Equity from Pension
funds and then they took more deposits
and then eventually they were rendered
insolvent and then at that point in the
bankruptcy you find out that a year and
a half early they just made a 500
million dollar boo-boo okay and that's
what you're finding out with Alameda you
will find out that oops it turns out
that like 12 months ago they lost three
billion dollars but they didn't tell
anybody they probably didn't tell
I bet you they didn't tell their Equity
investors yeah nobody puts a billion
dollars into a company with a 30 billion
dollar evaluation if you made billion
dollar trading errors or two billion
dollar trading errors so what you had
was a bunch of opaque private operators
that they were in essence lying
dissembling or it's like I didn't
technically lie because FTX didn't lose
the billion Alameda lost the billion and
the investors you know they should have
said wait a minute these two these
companies are all related parties and
unless I know the financials of Alameda
and paper bird and FTX and I can compose
it all there's no way that I can put
money in this and I think that you know
the answer is when you're private people
can cut all sorts of Corners when
they're doing private deals it's like so
Sequoia they're adults and they blow a
few hundred million dollars okay adults
doing stupid things but they're adults
who the hell negotiates that you give 2
billion without any board seats I mean
that's that's the part that I'm because
the back and forth of that when you give
that kind of money I mean it's just like
yeah we want some sort of accountability
by the way does this kind of there's
nothing right about it right there's
nothing appropriate about it but I
understand what he did I totally get no
it's nothing right about them investing
that's what I'm saying it was totally
inappropriate because you would ask for
a board
right yeah whoever gave the most out of
the two billion you have to be asking
about you have to be asking about
monthly reports to see what's going on
what do you mean you lost 3 billion we
don't know four year or I mean this that
doesn't make any sense to me the the
lack of accountability and by the way
that's what happens when you go a I'm
having dinner with uh Dave David Solomon
Goldman Sachs is a CEO a couple nights
ago in Miami and they're talking about
this right how 428 months economic
expansion what happens you start
becoming a little bit cocky you start
thinking this is going to be like this
forever you start thinking money is just
going to be Printing and he says yeah
here's a billion here's 100 million
here's 50 million here's 200 million and
then now all of a sudden everybody's
going back to what's your ebitda what's
the real business plan who's on your
team versus yeah we're going to turn
this 2 billion into 20 billion dollars
and our investors are going to love us
for it by the way does this kind of
validate
and I'm actually curious to know what
you say to this now not nine months ago
the fact that are you yourself sitting
there saying honestly I'm kind of like
hoping they figure out this regulation
thing fairly quickly sooner rather than
later are you leaning now towards more
regulation than maybe you were nine
months ago so they can filter out the
the actors of the game
look I I think that uh regulations a
good thing for the industry and I've
never really been against it if if if
you're uh holding Bitcoin or if you want
to act as a responsible sound
institution you don't have a problem
with regulation the people have been
fighting regulation are those that
actually want to sell the unregistered
Securities or manipulate them so
my position was always the the industry
should be regulated uh the roller
coaster ride that is Bitcoin is because
of unregistered Securities trading on
unregulated exchanges that that's why
Bitcoin is so volatile and so to the
extent that your life is miserable in
the Bitcoin world it's because of
unregulated exchanges manipulating
unregistered securities
so yeah I mean I I think that if we look
forward
you know what what's important people
sometimes they they can what is it they
think that
regulations a bad thing I mean it's
should you be able to cheat people like
like if you went on a vacation in the
Bahamas and someone put a gun to your
head stole all your money and beat you
half to death
and then you came back you know in a
Stretcher to the United States would you
then say I really appreciate the
unregulated environment in the Bahamas
I mean
certainly not taking a helicopter there
everybody so so everybody with regard to
the money they expect things to be fair
and equitable
right
and uh the real problem in the industry
is it's too hard or it's too easy for
unethical actors to victimize honest
people and so we need to fix that
whatever you call that
now if we look at the future of the
industry I'm gonna I'm gonna take a very
Pro crypto point of view for a second
which is here are the good things about
crypto
digital Commodities like Bitcoin that's
a good thing digital currencies like
Circle or tether a dollar that can move
at the speed of light to 8 billion
people on a mobile phone that would be a
good thing
digital Securities maybe you want to
create uh you know a Solana an ethereum
I don't have a problem with smart
contracts and all the rest it's just
that if there's a company or a set of
developers behind them they ought to
disclose who's making the decisions who
owns the stuff and what is my risk can
can they simply seize all of my money
tomorrow if they want or not so digital
Securities would also be a good thing
and then digital tokens if you're Katy
Perry and you want to issue a Katy Perry
token you don't want to spend 40 million
dollars on lawyers and accountants and
take three years to do it and spend 25
million a year to keep it current that
is the cost to issue an analog security
like Microsoft or like apple or like
microstrategy so it would be great and
it's very reasonable if you could issue
a digital token as one of a hundred
thousand celebrities and do it ethically
and and technically in a sound fashion
and maybe you spend a couple hundred
thousand dollars or you know a million
dollars to set it up but not a hundred
million and if you were to do a digital
security you ought to be able to do it
but it shouldn't be as hard
as uh as maybe it is to take public a
very complicated company now what's good
about those things 24 7 trading to 8
billion people personal property rights
to your iOS or Android phone the ability
for artists and creators to monetize
their brand and then with a commodity
the ability of a non-sovereign store of
value beyond the corrupting influence of
a company a CEO or a government those
are all the good things that's the
promise of digital assets or the crypto
industry smart contracts would also be a
good thing these are all good things
what's the problem the problem is most
of the ideas have been built on an
irresponsible or Foundation or an
unstable Foundation that is economically
they collapse and they're not engineered
properly or ethically they're not quite
right or there's no regulatory Clarity
so it's in the guys at uh Circle
they're not public a tether they're not
public well if you were going to have a
bank that held 500 billion dollars of
money and you issued 500 billion worth
of tokens wouldn't you think they ought
to actually have to make public
disclosures if the CEO dies over the
weekend and there's a new CEO don't you
think that you should tell the people
with the 500 billion dollars at risk
what's going on yeah well here's the
here's the challenge we are in a passive
aggressive environment right now which
is
which is um no one in the crypto
industry has been given a path to
register their asset with the SEC right
there's no obvious way to register a
digital commodity if you thought that
your token was a commodity you can't
just file a form and and get back an
answer there's no way to register a
digital currency the currency has been
caught in a fight between Treasury
Department the FDIC the C you know the
SEC and it's like how you know how do I
actually register one and what do I got
to do in order to be anointed as a ready
to trade token there's no way to
register a digital security there is no
definition no taxonomy of a token versus
security versus commodity versus a
currency most people don't even
understand what I just said define a
digital currency digital token digital
security digital commodity how many
lawmakers would give you a one paragraph
definition of the difference ethically
technically economically zero yeah so so
if you're an entrepreneur you're like
well I just if I come to the U.S what
can I do I can buy and hold Bitcoin what
else can I do legally nothing
okay I'm a publicly traded company a
microstrategy what do we do we buy and
we hold Bitcoin
why do we do it because that's a
regulatory Safe Harbor and an ethical
Safe Harbor
everybody agrees that's a commodity
everything else you know there there is
no obvious path forward so if we want a
progressive environment
you know uh people in DC The Regulators
and or the lawmakers they have to say
here's a definition of a digital
currency you want to register it
register it with the SEC or with
treasury they can't decide who to
register it with
cfdc SEC treasury probably the SEC
ought to be the first stop everybody
sends their token to the SEC and the SEC
says you're you're either ethical or
unethical like you know if you're a
Ponzi scheme they should just reject it
right but if you're ethical they say
this is the disclosure we need from you
you're a commodity you're a currency
your security
what's the difference between Katy Perry
token and uh Apple stock trading on a
digital exchange well clearly I think
you could you could agree that apple is
a much more complicated company than
Katy Perry fan token would be so
presumably Apple spends 100 million
dollars a year to stay in compliance
with Securities Law Katy Perry shouldn't
have to spend 100 million a year to
actually issue a token and so
what we're waiting for is for someone to
give us a taxonomy and a process and the
deadlock at Congressional level was
stuck
the way this gets solved is either the
SEC just publishes the guideline they
could do it right if you want if you're
the chair of the SEC you could just put
out a 20-page memo and say this is the
way it's going to be and everybody would
just fall in line within the next 12
months almost certainly or Congress has
got to put out a law
and the law is going to say these are
the classes of digital assets and this
is the regulator that gets to
that it gets to register you and then
you know what is a digital Exchange
a digital exchange is uh 24 7 365
trading venue like a coinbase or like a
binance so so you see the traditional
world is a hundred trillion dollars of
analog securities
trading on traditional exchanges that
trade 9 30 to 4 in the afternoon Monday
through Friday except on Bankers
holidays and the problem with that
service level is bad it disenfranchises
7 billion people you can't take personal
custody of your Apple stock on your
Android phone that's not going to happen
right and so it's and your Bankers have
Monopoly on your assets you can't lend
or borrow against your assets except
through the bank that controls them so
there's lots of monopolies in the
traditional world and they're not
evolving
Well a different a different idea would
be a digital exchange world where
everything circulated 24 7 365 you could
take custody of it on your phone
what if I could take a share of Apple
stock and sap it to someone in Zimbabwe
and they could take it in Coal storage
on a hardware wallet like they could
really own it you think we're going that
direction
no I think I I think uh I think I've
laid out the most Progressive policy
which is a world where digital assets
a hundred thousand digital assets
circulate to eight billion people with
full empowerment
I don't think we'll get there I think
the best we can get to is a few digital
exchanges that are regulated the trade a
few dozen assets you know if you know a
dozen stable coins a dozen crypto assets
that are either Securities or
Commodities that have passed through
regulatory jurisprudence or regulatory
review and I think 98 of all the stuff
that circulates in the ecosystem is
probably going to get squeezed out
most of the crypto entrepreneurs get
squeezed out and the control of the
industry is going to move to the
fidelities and the blocks and the you
know a publicly traded regulated company
or Bank in the US or in Europe that's
got an army of lawyers and accountants
behind it layman's terms how do you
explain uh the difference between
centralization regulation or
decentralization or or deregulation if
you were to explain that to a sixth
grader
a decentralized asset is one that is so
diffused on so many different computers
in the hands of so many people that no
one person can change it or corrupt it
means Bill Gates can't corrupt it the
head of the SEC can't corrupt it a
president of you know the head of Russia
or the U.S or the UAE can't corrupt it
no company can corrupt it if I own a
billion dollars of it I can't corrupt it
and so a decentralized asset is like a
is like the cold virus you get the cold
a billionaire gets the cold you both
have the same cold the billionaire
doesn't duck the cold you can't give the
billionaire a different coal than you
got it is just a force of nature we all
equally share and you know benefit and
suffer if I give you an orange and I
give a billionaire an orange and I give
the head of Russia and orange you all
got the same orange nobody gets a better
deal that is a decentralized commodity a
centralized asset
it's like Apple stock you know if Tim
Cook gets up and decides to print 10
million more shares of Apple stock he
could
if Tim Cook decides to cut the price of
the iPhone to zero like Mark Zuckerberg
here's an example of the risk of owning
a security Zuckerberg decides that
Facebook should be meta
and the price of the stock Falls by 65
percent and and is it legal and ethical
for him to do it yeah if you bought
Facebook stock you read the report you
know he controls the company you know
he's the CEO you know he could do it you
can complain about it but that was the
risk you had going into it
you're never going to wake up and be
holding an orange in your hand and find
out that some dude that hates you around
the world cast a magic spell and made
two-thirds of your orange disappear you
see
so one of these things is a natural
asset the other is an artificial asset
Securities are man-made assets
Commodities are nature created assets
they both come with risks
but when you buy a bar of gold and you
lose money it's not because the CEO of
gold Corp
made the gold copper
right and then made it like rot away on
you right goal it is what it is it's a
natural risk not and so that's why
Securities laws are structured such that
the liabilities of officers of companies
lie in the manipulation of the
securities
and and so if I was explaining it to a a
kid in school I would just say
a truly decentralized thing results in a
commodity where no one can corrupt it
and a centralized thing is a security
you're relying upon the effort of
somebody else and you have to trust them
and if you trust them you may get a
benefit
but you know just like trusting a bank
you know when you when you own someone's
fiat currency you trust the government
not to print more when you put your
money in a bank you trust the bank to
give their money back to you and when
you buy a stock you trust the CEO or the
management team not to destroy the
company through an aptitude or not to
dilute your stock by you know just
giving it all to themself secretly and
not telling you I got two other
questions before we wrap up we got 18
minutes let's see if we can pull this
off or not so I don't know if you
remember or not that article came out
talking about the fact that uh you know
how Bitcoin uh matches I don't remember
the exact number 74 of the time uh it
was not sorry it was 74 of the last 90
days every time the market went up
Bitcoin went up every time the market
went down Bitcoin went down I don't know
if you remember this or not it's an
article that came out probably you know
nine months ago eight months ago even
around the time that we sat down
together they tracked the correlation
between
right but now Dao went all the way down
to 28 okay SMP went down to I want to
say 3300 I don't know the exact number
I'm say 33 something maybe even 3280
give or take
and then that was up right now how much
is that can you look at what S P 500 is
at right now I don't know what they said
that was at 33.9 by the end of the day
SMP is 4080. now three thirty nine
thirty nine okay perfect so what if you
look at the rolling 12 lowest was what
52 week low 34.91 Okay so 34.91
but if you look at Bitcoin go on bitcoin
at the same time and let's look at what
bitcoin's at uh uh Bitcoin Bitcoin is
currently at 16. okay but if you go high
high is what for the year I want to say
50 rolling 12. go one year go one year
one year one year right there no that's
one month go to one year one year is
that what 50 something uh if you go all
the way at the top go all the way at the
top 50 something so
um
gold they would say if you print money
gold will go up inflation goes up gold
will go up right Bitcoin was matching
the market now it's not matching the
market at least it was matching the
market when the market was going up now
the market went up and if you look at
this it's flatlining and going lower and
lower slightly right if you look at
every time it comes down pumps Spike up
every time it comes out boom Spike up
comes down boom Skype Spike up
today Draper comes out and says by the
end of next year you know Bitcoin is
going to go up to you know 250
000 I think he said that earlier today
but at the same time he was supportive
of Elizabeth Holmes till the very end so
you know when you look at some of this
stuff and you compare them with the
numbers that you see
why why isn't Bitcoin no longer
responding to the market the way it was
before and now it's kind of the
correlation is no longer the same what
do you think is the cause of that
I mean Bitcoin goes through phases where
it's either positively correlated to
risk assets or is negatively correlated
or it's uncorrelated and it all comes
down to the the micro Dynamics like how
are all the exchanges and all the other
crypto Traders how are they behaving and
then the macro Traders how are the macro
Traders perceiving it and that's
continually evolving let me uh let me
give you one interesting stat you know
like on August 10th microstrategy
decided to get into this business so
August 10 2020. so if you go back to the
summer of 2020 when it was it was just
unclear what are all these assets going
to do you said August 10th August 10th
so I I track this because this is my
scorecard because on August 11th we
announced we bought a quarter billion
dollars worth of bitcoin and we've been
long Bitcoin ever since
if you had taken a billion dollars and
you had bought bonds like long bonds
20-year Bonds in the summer of 2020 and
held them through today you would be
down 19 8 to 10 19 the b-o-n-d index is
minus 19 that's what I'm saying a
billion dollars will be 810 million
dollars yeah if you bought gold you'd be
down 13 okay if you had bought the
NASDAQ
you would be up three percent
it pretty much chopped sure right if you
had bought the s p index you would be up
19 not not bad not bad sure not bad if
you bought Bitcoin you'd be up 43
Bitcoin doubled the performance of those
other assets even as it got beat around
the ears and if you had gone into big
Tech and you bought Google you'd be up
34 not as good as Bitcoin but better
than NASDAQ Apple's up 30 Microsoft is
up 19 about 20 so those three are
monopolies the three most powerful
Technologies in the world but Netflix
down 34 Amazon down 42 and facebook
slash meta down 54 and that's why NASDAQ
chopped sideways now what is the what is
the point well Bitcoin is really
volatile no doubt about it it's hair on
fire but if you and if you're gonna be
an investor for less than 12 months you
were just a Speculator and you're a
Trader and God bless you if you go short
you make some money if you pick it right
but if you pick wrong get your face
ripped off and I don't know how to do
that I mean you have to be a Trader but
if your time Horizon is four years two
years four years eight years Beyond and
if you're buying it as a long-term store
of value Asset and you're just are you
disgusted
with the manipulation of the fiat
currency
then you buy Bitcoin because you're
angry that they keep printing more pesos
and boulevards and dollars and Euros are
you disgusted that the CEO of your
favorite company screwed you by making
bad decisions I won't name the company
fill on your own
then you're going to buy Bitcoin there's
no CEO Bitcoin are you you know so if
you if you want to escape
that uh that particular risk and what
you want to do is you don't want to
trust a CEO a company a government or
anybody and if you want to buy something
that you can hold for 30 years
well I can tell you I can't pick a
single company that I would want to hold
30 years I can't you know there's not a
piece of land I would hold for 30 years
because I don't know that the mayor
wouldn't
you know the guy that replaces the mayor
next might decide to Triple the property
tax and you know so there are a lot of
things in this world that are just very
risky
Bitcoin fits in a portfolio and it's
performing just fine as long as you have
a a two-year plus time Horizon and if
you have a short time Horizon if you
want to look at 12 weeks 18 weeks one
year every single investment in the last
12 months looks pretty hideous and I can
probably tell you that you know if you
lost 20 percent of your money you're a
fool if you lost 40 percent you feel
like a bigger fool if you lost 60 you
feel like a bigger fool so
Real Estate Investors Securities
investors Bond investors crypto
investors Bitcoin investors there's no
winners in the current environment on a
short time frame other than the shorts
the guys that are just short hedging
somebody I mean I can I can say this one
thing you know haven't been uh series
seven since uh 2001 you know financial
industry 20 plus years myself not at
your level you you'll see mutual funds
that have come out with their prospectus
and you look at the date they run in
since this time and since that time we
can run dates to make your argument
Better or Worse everybody can do it we
can do it you can everybody can do it
right uh some may say well you know
microstrate the article that came out
saying the fact that you guys lost 1.8
billion dollars right and that happened
by the way did you guys have a margin
call or no did you get margin closer no
no it's not okay so oh and I didn't and
I didn't toot our own horn but I will
say while we're at it we all perform
Bitcoin we're at 54 microstrategy stock
has outperformed every big Tech 95 types
in the Nasdaq all the asset classes
while we'd been
criticized for losing money on bitcoin
so why is it saying you guys lost 1.8
billion there
when uh Bitcoin got to fifty thousand
dollars a coin
we sold a billion dollars worth of stock
at 700 a share we converted the equity
into Bitcoin Bitcoin traded down and so
technically the Bitcoin that we bought
at that point is worth less today and so
you can say that's a non 20 bought a 32k
or 39K something like that you bought it
at 39 000. if you bought Bitcoin more
than the current trading price then you
can say that you lost money buying it
but if you actually paid for it with
cash or Equity that was valued
proportionate then you've actually
created shareholder value we've actually
created Enterprise Value the company's
Enterprise Value is expanded by a factor
of five
our shareholders have made a made more
money than any other investment so
they're all fine
people are just cherry picking random
trading periods in order to make some
observation got it and in this story
here to the ethereum folks who would
love for me to ask you this question
there's no second best microstrategy
would be up 1.6 billion if it invested
in ethereum this was a month ago what
are your thoughts on this wonderful
article the problem is ethereum is a
security right I mean look I don't mean
to be mean about it but but it's pretty
evident vitalik is the CEO of ethereum
there is a 10-year road map with 160
blocks one of the little blocks in the
road map says elect secret leader
another block is give people the ability
to unstake their coin another block is
set the monetary policy like ethereum is
an incomplete uh crypto Network it's a
work in progress and so the problem
fundamentally is it's a security which
means to promote a security is
Securities fraud it's just it's that
simple right when you're promoting a
theorem you're promoting Joe Lubin and
vitalik's Company and it's their token
there was a pre-mine there's an Ico they
change the monetary policy and they
currently are holding 20 billion dollars
worth of their their investors assets
hostage
and we don't know when the money will be
released so here's the issue at some
point the SEC is going to deem them as
security if they are security it's
illegal to trade them on any exchange
you know in the U.S
really in the world right I mean and
unless someone creates a path to
register a digital security look I would
have nothing against ethereum if they
said look we're a company this is a
security we're going to register it okay
what's the board of directors who owns
it what's the rules give us all the risk
factors I mean a very simple question do
you know who's going to make the
decision to give the 20 billion dollars
of eth back
because there is no representation as to
when you'll be able to unstake eth it's
not clear who makes the decision
is it one what happens if that one
person disappears what if they decide to
never give you your wreath back
okay that that is a problem so as a
publicly traded company I'm going to
make a technical argument
publicly traded companies can't hold
more than 40 percent of their balance
sheet in a security like if it was Apple
stock and it had a hundred thousand
pages of disclosures I still couldn't
hold more than 40 percent of my balance
sheet in it because uh you know an
operating company can't hold any more
Securities without becoming SEC 40
reporting company it's a totally uh
different thing
so technically we couldn't buy
Securities if we wanted to
and uh and otherwise
look bitcoin's protocol has been pretty
much set in stone with a series of only
soft forks for 13 and a half 14 years
ethereum changes every six months those
you know and so it's a different thing
you know as for back testing it I mean I
I could go back and say what if I had
bought such and such yo-yo coin token
too but but as I've said the 22 000
tokens nearly all of them are
unregistered Securities which means
they're trading illegally unethically on
on illegal exchanges what could go wrong
like I wouldn't put a penny
into any of those tokens if you said you
know My Cousin Vinnie's you know got
yo-yo dine and do you want to buy some
of the penny stock and just trust me
it's like no I mean it's no different
than boiler room right or you know the
Wolf of Wall Street
right the ethereum people have a they
have an aggressive technical ambition
But ultimately it's not a complete
project they've got a 10-year road map
when it's complete
five years after that you'll know if it
breaks or doesn't break and at some
point there's the question of you know
is it decentralized or not it's pretty
obviously not decentralized when you're
waiting for the supreme leader to give
you the plan
final question on uh this uh what's his
name this top customer service
representative who became a billionaire
Elon Musk who just bought Twitter do you
have any opinions on uh Elon Musk what
he's doing with Twitter
I I think that uh Twitter's coming back
to life I think it's I think Twitter had
too many training wheels on it you know
too much governance on it if you look at
any economy I mean any economy at all I
mean the recipe for crippling the
economy is too many well-intentioned
bureaucrats regulating and everything
telling you what you can and you can't
do Ronald Reagan you know fixed the U.S
economy or if Margaret Thatcher the
intelligent thing they do is when they
deregulate get out of the way and stop
second guessing the people
I think on Twitter I mean they they
asked so many accounts right when you
ask people that disagree with the
current thing and you obliterate their
accounts it's very chilling
and so uh Elon has I I do believe that
his motivation is give free speech to
the world I think it's a very
complicated thing to do when there are
so many laws about what's acceptable
speech and what isn't
but um I think that uh that uh Twitter
was kind of stuck in a malaise and uh
they were they were basically they're
they're a digital Monopoly on public
speech and they were siphoning off all
of their energy simply to regulate
the speech and when you step back and
say what if we just let people talk and
we and we put our energy into improving
the product
like make the product better I mean
there's no reason why you can't provide
like give 100 million people the ability
to get verified why didn't they do that
it was it was a very they had a very
Socialist Communist idea which is 300
000 blue checks and no amount of money
or effort on your part will get you
verified so 300 million proletariat
proletarians and 300 000 Elite and even
if you wanted to write me a ten thousand
dollar check to verify you I'm not
taking it so it was very stuck and uh
well some employees took some checks and
they gave verification behind closed
doors what I tell them same thing with
insta yeah and the same thing happens in
communist regimes where you have
rationing it's invariably of a black
market form so I think that Elon is he's
making moves to improve the process
improve the functionality open up free
speech there should be debate people
should not live in fear
of what they say you say the wrong thing
you express the wrong opinion and your
account gets locked and you get Shadow
banned and I think that that undermined
the use of the platform
and uh and so I you know I'm in favor of
where they're headed I I think it's good
for the world I think it's auspicious
it's going to be a bumpy ride like most
most of the time when with elon's
business they're all bumpy rides Tesla
was a bumpy ride but he likes that but
you know when you step back you're like
Tesla's a bumpy ride but it looks like
we're getting to the point where cars
will drive themselves and you start to
think well maybe when we get to the end
of the ride it'll be a good thing last
question for you on my end
um
this Bitcoin having that happens every
four years obviously you're very
familiar with this so the next having is
March of 2024 correct
um where do you see Bitcoin in March of
2024 so if we do another interview 15
months from now best case scenario for
Bitcoin I think we're really close to
the bottom of the deleveraging cycle I
think we've taken out a lot of the Bad
actors I think that a fire is lit under
the DC
uh the D.C politicians and The
Regulators I think that we're going to
get clarity and I think that that
Clarity is going to bring in a bunch of
institutional money a bunch of
institutional Banks and big investors
and big corporations and at some point
you know maybe not between now and then
the Year we're gonna get to the to the
bottom of the market and then we're
going to begin the next Bull Run and I
think uh I think that we'll be midway
into a really nice Bull Run and and
Bitcoin is going to be you know Way
north of where it is right now by the
north of the high of sixty thousand or
north of a hundred thousand or you know
I you know I don't want to give a hard
number because it would be irresponsible
of me but I just feel like Bitcoin has
has uh suffered the deleveraging like
that you know guys like FTX they took 10
billion dollars and then they Panic sold
it our fire sales sold billions of
dollars of assets and that's what's got
us to where we are once all of the Bad
actors and all of the irresponsible
players have fire sold and you know
Panic sold all of their Bitcoin then uh
what you've done is you've transferred
it into a much stronger hands and so I
just I I think that certainly we ought
to be back to a solid place what you're
saying is the future looks bright I
think the future is definitely there you
go folks if you learn as much as I did
give it a thumbs up subscribe please
give a channel and uh we're gonna put
the link to Mr Saylor's Twitter account
for you to go there and follow them give
them feedback about today's thing every
time you're here I learn man I get
smarter and smarter it's like my brain
is having a workout
listening to you and the muscles are
getting more and more cut up I
appreciate you for coming out really
enjoyed it tomorrow we're doing a home
team podcast it's just going to be us we
may have a surprise podcast sometime
this week with somebody that's currently
a controversial figure not who you think
but maybe maybe we'll see we'll see Even
Adam doesn't know about it because we'll
keep it a secret until this thing
becomes verified Michael appreciate you
for coming out truly thank you thank you